Freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
Folge Eintag persönlicher Koch eine
Folge die wir schon lange lange lange
ins Leben rufen wollten und heute ist er
endlich da Aaron freut mich sehr Dich
zuü ich glaub seit zwei Jahren oder so
gehe ich dir auf den Sack ne ja aber
jetzt bin ich da und ich habe Hunger
mitgebracht und ich freue mich schon
wenn ich das alles sehe auch gut für die
Zuschauer die immer schreiben hol doch
mal den und den ich habe es schon
versucht die Antworten nur nicht immer
oder ich will jetzt
niem nein ich will niemanden ang sag mir
nam ger komm würdest du dir wünchen ich
will das nicht machen das ist asozial
nein ich bin aber asozial deswegen knoss
habe ich paar Mal du Penner ja okay nein
l mal jetzt
mach ich noch gestern gesehen ich habe
schon gedacht wenn aon in meinem Video
ist wird wenigstens nicht unangenehm
aber es wird natürlich trotzdem
unangenehm jetzt machen richtig ruft den
auch noch an
natürlich was los Jens guck mal ich bin
hier mit Max und der will einen Tag dein
Koch sein und du antwortest nicht habe
ich nie gesehen es ist überhaupt nicht
schim ich wollte nicht dass er dich
anruft wenn du mal Lust darauf hast dann
würde ich liebend gerne mal für dich
Kochen ich habe Aron gesagt der sollte
dich nicht anrufen er wollte mich
bloßstellen hat jetzt damit geschafft
machen wir geil super super ich gebe
euch gegenseitig die Nummer knossi
tschüss ciao ciao da muss man ja sagen
Jens ist der Liebste Typ der Welt ja
Frühstück erstmal das war jetzt schon
wirklich sehr unangenehm okay wir machen
ein full English Breakfast bzw nicht
ganz so full sondern das was du dir
gewünscht hast wir machen schönes
geröstetes Brot geile bratenwürste viel
bacon Baked Beans die wir noch mal
ordentlich pimpen und dazu ein schönes
cremiges rührein das ist es du hast
jetzt die freie Wahl du kannst dich
entweder ganz entspannt an Tisch setzen
Arbeiten okay Ciao eine knoblauchzeehe
habe ich hier ein bisschen fein gehackt
weiter geht's mit unserem panchetta
geben sie hier in einen Topf wo wir sie
schön auslassen und ich finde wirklich
die sieht wunderschön aus während wir
das machen kümmern wir uns schon mal um
unsere Würste ich wünschte es wären
original britische bangers also diese
klassischen britischen Würstchen da
gehen wir ein bisschen Öl drüber so dass
sie schön bedeckt sind und wir machen
das ganz geil den restlichen Platz vom
Blech nutzen wir einfach gleich für den
Bacon und dann haben wir diese perfekte
Kombination aus allem es kann eigentlich
nur lecker werden also ab in den Ofen
200° vorgeheizt los geht's da drüben
lassen wir jetzt die panchetta aus
ansonsten machen wir wie gesagt noch ein
schönes Rührei so wie ich es liebe soft
scrambled also Eier aufschlagen Ei
verquölen wobei ich das glaube ich
relativ zum Ende erst in die Pfanne
geben werde was aber relativ lange
braucht wird unsere Tomate sein das
heißt ich mach schon mal die pfansche an
machen einfach so eine schöne typische
Tomate das ist wirklich die schönste
Tomate die man im deutschen Winter
bekommen kann sehr schön weich einmal so
aufgeschnitten auf der Schnittkante
gegrillt kann nur geil werden unsere
panchetta hat richtig schön Farbe es ist
wirklich wunderschön finde ich wie die
geworden ist ne so richtig streifig
knusprig knurblauch dazu wenn ihr das zu
Hause nachmacht scharf mögt gibt jetzt
noch ein bisschen Chili an der Stelle da
rein wevor der braun wird gehen wir auch
schon direkt unsere beans dazu einfach
die klassischen dann gehen wir auch
direkt mit der Temperatur runter sodass
die einfach nur einmal warm werden die
sollen sich nicht groß in der Konsistenz
verändern und fertig sind die gepimpten
breakfast beans hier direkt ein bisschen
Oliven Öl auf die planscher und die
Tomate drauf jeder kriegt gleich eine
als nächstes ein schönerleib
Sauerteigbrot oh mit einer Krume wie sie
nicht schöner sein könnte das röste ich
in Scheiben an weil dieses Brot macht
jedes Frühstück besser das wird einfach
nicht alt geiles Brot Olivenöl
Röststoffe geht nicht besser ist einfach
so wir legen auf jeden Fall jetzt zu
unseren Würstchen ein paar Scheiben
Bacon einfach aufs heiße Blech dazu oh
der zischt direkt leicht vor sich hin
und brutzelt sogar schon so ein bisschen
das ist ser geil ja die Solid gut
Mittelwert bisschen dicker als gekauft
schaut euch das einfach mal an
mancheiner würde hier sagen dass ist
vielleicht schon zu viel ich find es
gerade richtig das darf richtig Farbe
bekommen ja jetzt gerade warten wir
eigentlich nur auf den Backofen und wenn
das fertig ist gib ihm jetzt schaut euch
das einfach mal an auf einem Blech
knuspriger Bacon und geile Würste leider
aufgeplatzt aber sind wir ehrlich das
macht überhaupt nichts Pfanne heizt vor
alles andere ist ready nehmen wir uns
einen ordentlichen Stich Butter ab in
die Pfanne perfekt der schmilzt uns
schön weg und wenn er geschmolzen ist
kommt unser Ei hinein die Butter ist
geschmolzen und unser Ei kommt H nein
alles auf einmal und dann wie es bei
einem schönen soft scrambl egg ist von
Anfang an rühren s dass wir diese
kleinen leichten Flocken haben und mutig
sein nicht komplett durchbraten geiler
geht auch null kom nichts wenn die
Pfanne gut vorgeheizt ist so unser rüer
ist fertig dann würde ich sagen richten
wir jetzt einfach nur noch
[Musik]
an
du hast richtig Hunger ich habe so ein
hung dann bist du der Einzige der zwei
sausages bekommt ich bin gleich zurück
mit meinem Teller und noch einer anderen
wichtigen Sache das stimmt der gute
Heinz ja geil das ist unser Frühstück ja
Dave heute als Überraschungsgast auch
dabei bei diesem Dreh ist wieder mal
alles ein bisschen anders als sonst
erstmal das wichtigste das ist ja für
mich ein Hotelfrühstück so muss wirklich
das sein und jetzt musst du wissen ist
deine Aufgabe folgende du probierst
alles ein bisschen kleines Poker Face
und dann geht die Kamera aus das heißt
wir essen zu dritt ganz in Ruhe auf am
Ende musst du dann eine Bewertung
Stellen okay ja deshalb lass dir nicht
so viel anmerken Tomate solide war so
eine ganze Tomate ich date du schneidest
die kleiner bin auch nicht sauer nur
enttäuscht die Bohen sind bombastisch
ich glaube das reicht als erster
Eindruck wir sehen uns gleich wieder
wenn wir aufgegessen haben so die Teller
sind leer geputzt Aaron du darfst heute
bewerten Dave vielleicht kannst Du Dich
anschließen vielleicht nicht aber leg
mal los was sagst du also die Bohnen
waren grandios mit dem Speck drin sowas
kleines liebe ich geil das Ei war hatte
eine gute Konsistenz ich musste Salz
drauf machen aber ist vollkommen fein
Brot war Bombe die Wurst da kann man
jetzt auch nicht viel falsch und nicht
richtig machen Bo ich weiß nicht was
geben die anderen so ich hätte jetzt
mein Bauchgefühl hätte gesagt es war
lecker es war sehr gut ich merke schon
du bist nicht ganz begeistert das auch
gut kan es war es war sehr gut es war
das perfekte Frühstück ungesund das hat
mir geschmeckt und dementsprechend aber
ja ich bei bei einer 7,5 von Z geil ist
ist es gut oder ist ist absolut fair
darauf können wir nämlich geil aufbauen
weil jetzt werde ich mir beim
Mittagessen richtig Mühe geben hast du
dir gerade gar keine Mühe gegeben nein
war überhaupt Werte den Teller mit
Spucke ich oder da beim Mittagessen du
kein Spaß du hast Dir gewünscht entweder
ein Caesar Salad oder ein Schnitzel nein
ich habe wieder geschrieben hey wenn ich
gesund leben will Caesar Salad und der
muss auch geil sein da muss das Hähnchen
muss perform und ohne diesen Fisch drin
oder ein Schnitzel am Schnitzel ist und
okay du hast schon Hähnchen vorausgzen K
cerell hat ja gar kein Hähnchen deshalb
mache ich dir ich ma dir ein Caesar
Salad mit einem Hähnchen katzu also mit
dem Hähnchen Schnitzel oh du kriegst
quasi beides ist du auch wieder mit und
schon mal rotzt dich rein gerne okay wir
sehen uns in der Küche wieder und das
beim Caesar Salad nicht fehlen darf sind
ein paar schöne krotor ich habe hier
einfach ein Brot so ein aufbackbrot das
schneide ich einmal in paar dicke
Scheiben und dann schneide ich mir
schöne Würfel raus schön knusprig dazu
geb ich ein bisschen Olivenöl ab in Ofen
und lass die während wir alles andere
machen schön knusprig werden der
Backofen ist vorgeheizt und ich gebe
einfach auf mein Blech drauf unsere
Würfel ihr wisst Leute bei persönlicher
Koch darf man nicht auf Kalorien gucken
es war mit Absicht das gleiche Blech von
vorhin so dass wir noch ein bisschen
baconfett dabei haben also es kann
einfach nur geil werden und ab in den
Ofen so der Salat ist geschnitten und
wir machen das jetzt so wir Salzen auch
den Salat ordentlich weil warum sollte
man warum Salz man alles außer Salat
Salat hat es auch verdient nach etwas zu
schmecken so und dann habe ich noch eine
kleine Erweiterung muss nicht in Caesar
Salad aber Cocktail Tomaten machen das
Ganze auf jeden Fall viel
abwechslungsreicher viel leckerer
deshalb haben wir die auch dabei also
nehme ich mir einfach die Tomaten von
der Rispe runter und ich habe gelernt
letztens von Bern zeher dass man Tomaten
am besten nicht so aufschneidet sondern
so rum weil so liegen die immer schön
der Juice kommt nicht raus sondern
bleibt schön stehen du hast immer eine
schöne gleichförmige Schnittkante sieht
schon viel geiler aus wenn man es so rum
macht auch die Tomaten kriegen ein wenig
Salz dann geen wir sie einfach mit in
die Schüssel alright jetzt ist es Zeit
für unser Dressing und klassisches
Caesar drressing braucht ein wenig
Arbeit wir nehmen uns eine Knoblauchzehe
öffnen die einmal und schneide ich mir
die einmal klein hol den Strunk raus
weil sonst wird's zu knoblauchlastig wir
werden den Knoblauch nicht ganz einfach
Würfeln sondern wir werden ih am Ende
des Tages zu einer Paste verarbeiten das
heißt ich schneid erstmal ein bisschen
vor wenn unser Knoblauch so aussieht
können wir ein wenig Salz dazu geben das
ist quasi so um den Knoblauch ein
bisschen aufzureiben weil ab jetzt
hacken wir ein bisschen aber gehen
abwechseln auch mal mit dem Messer
drüber und drücken den so ein bisschen
platt bis wir eben unsere Paste haben
unsere Paste besteht nicht nur aus
Knoblauch sondern auch aus sadellen und
Aaron meinte dass er gar nicht der
größte Fan davon ist meinte auf gar
keinen Fall irgendwie sadellen drauf so
gerollte sadellen und so was ich auf
jeden Fall ein bisschen fühle man
schmeckt die wirklich nicht im Dress ist
ist einfach so ein bisschen diese umami
Komponente rein damit und das gan
genauso fein haacken wir haben die ganze
Zeit gehackt und währendessen ein
bisschen die coutons vergessen schauen
wir mal rein wie die aussehen und oh ja
sie sehen auf jeden Fall knusprig aus
eigentlich geil man sieht hier aber
direkt wie sich auch so ein bisschen
Kondens bildet ich glaub dadurch werden
die wieder ein bisschen softer so ich
habe mir den Arm wund gehackt aber das
hier ist unsere Paste und ich finde sie
kann sich wirklich sehen lassen man hat
so dieses feinporige und es ist schon
eine besondere Konsistenz die man
dadurch erzielt das geben wir jetzt
einmal in unsere Schüssel hinein und
dann ergänzen wir die restlichen Zutaten
für unser Dressing dafür brauchen wir
einmal ein Ei das Trennen wir allerdings
auf denn wir brauchen nur das Ei gelb
denn das bindet unser Dressing das gebe
ich einmal dazu außerdem gehen wir ein
bisschen Wester Soße dazu wcher ich habe
letztens noch ein Video gesehen weil die
mir alle immer schreibt dass es falsch
ist so ich spiele das jetzt einmal ab
das ist mir jetzt gerade persönlich
wichtig wiser das sagen die Locals also
wistischer ein bisschen wisticher Soße
geben wir dazu die Genin Teelöffel auch
nicht fehlen darf eine Prise Salz und
dann fangen wir schon mal an das Ganze
zu verquürlen einfach erstmal so wie es
jetzt gerade ist zu so einer kleinen
Paste und dann kommt wie bei jedem
Dressing unser Öl zum Einsatz einfach
ein schönes Olivenöl dass wir nach und
nach dazu träufeln bis unsere Soße
cremig wird schön emolgiert man hat auch
direkt eine ordentliche Menge von dem
Dressing ne ist schon hab schon eine
ganz schöne Konsistenz jetzt komme ich
mit ein bisschen Zitrone um die Ecke
könnt ja bisschen anrollen dann kommt
der Saft besser raus alter Trick ne
durch die Hand pressen falls doch Kerne
rauskommen bleiben sie liegen wie oft
habe ich das schon gezeigt Eric weiter
rühren bisschen Pfeffer dran und jetzt
nehmen wir uns eine Reibe Parmesan und
reiben noch jede Menge Parmesan in unser
Dressing das gibt dann diesen bekannten
cremigen Caesar Dressing Geschmack wir
haben unser Dressing noch ein bisschen
abgeschmeckt noch ein bisschen süße
hinzu gegeben jetzt gebe ich das einmal
auf den Salat drauf nicht alles auf
einmal weil wir haben schon echt eine
ordentliche Menge rausbekommen dann hebe
ich das mal ein bisschen durch
liches Dressing falls ihr euch fragt was
in dieser Pfanne ist die hier vor uns
steht das ist wagio fett nicht weil wir
so dick auftragen wollen sondern weil
wir es einfach noch übrig hatten von dem
meces Video deshalb werden wir gleich
etwas darin friittieren weiter geht's
mit unserer Hühnerbrust wer erstmal die
innenf ist raustrennen die ist relativ
flach aber wir halbieren die noch einmal
weil dann hat so diesen perfekten kurz
frittierten juicy Geschmack also jetzt
wäre Butterfly wir gehen aber einmal
komplett durch s dass wir diese dünnen
Hähnchenschnitzel haben und die ziehen
wir gleich durch unsere panierstraße und
dafür haben wir mehl Eier und penco
breadcumbs also ein bisschen asiatische
knusprige Brotkrumen ich beginne indem
ich mein Hähnchen erstmal hier ins Mehl
lege dann gehen wir als nächstes unser
Hähnchen ins Ei wenden es hier einmal
und so guter Letzt in die pancor
brotkrum so dass von allen Seiten gut
bedeckt ist und es wird wirklich einfach
komplett knusprig auf diese Art und
Weise und das machen wir jetzt mit allen
unseren hähnchenpieces und dann nehme
ich mir mein chicken und lege es hier in
die Pfanne mit vagio Fett etwa auf 180°
ist die und ich sage euch ganz ehrlich
wie soll es nicht lecker sein ich meine
Panko Fried Chicken vagio Fett es kann
wirklich nur gut sein aber hab ein
Kritiker da draußen sitzen deshalb
schauen wir mal und jetzt guckt euch das
einfach mal an perfektes Format
goldenbraun knusprig in wagu Fett
ausgebacken kann man nur feiern wird
geil und wenn alles fertig frittiert ist
müssen wir nur noch
[Musik]
anrichten so Aaron Schnitzel oder Salat
wir machen einfach beides ich bin sehr
gespannt jetzt ist die Frage es sieht
super aus es riecht sehr gut meine Frage
ist gibt sowas nicht so so ein Salat
fertig bei Aldi und dann diese
fertigchnütze und du hast das jetzt
einfach nur so und fertig ich habe mir
schon gedacht wenn man die ganze Zeit
Leute hops nimmt so wie du dann ist man
bestimmt auch paranoid dass man zurück
verarscht wird aber ich kann dir sagen
ich habe gerade in der Küche gekocht
nicht wenig deshalb hoffe ich dass es
dir schmeckt wir probieren das ganze
aber also ich weiß gar nicht wie die
Soße heißt oder Cesar Dressing okay das
Dressing riecht schon mal gut hast du es
auch selbst gemacht ja komplett ah
wirklich ja sicher ich ich dir doch
keine fertig Produkt Salat 1A und jetzt
hast du gesagt das Hähnchen muss
überzeugen ne du hast es auch selbst
mariniert oder paniert na sicher habe
ich das selbst paniert du ich habe kann
SAS alles als ob ich hier gleich in der
Küche stehe und dir so ein fertiges sch
am Ende das war ein placement von kau
weil die haben alles was man braucht
nein nein ich habe es komplett selbst
gemacht aber das Hähnchen also D muss
ich sagen das Hähnchen beste geil also
das Hähnchen
ist jetzt wirst es du wirst es nicht
rausmecken man kann es auch nicht
rausschmecken aber es ist schon sehr
saftig ne ich habe das Hähnchen in wagu
Fett frittiert wow ich weiß nicht was
das ist aber ich B super das ist sehr
sehr teures rinfleisch okay aber der
Salat ist auch sehr knackig Poker Face
muss jetzt aber auch gewaht bleiben
deshalb sehen wir uns gleich wieder wenn
es an die Bewertung geht ich packe dir
noch ein Schnitzel drauf oder oh bitte
bitte Teller leer gutes Zeichen was
gibst du der ganze Nummer ich bin immer
noch so ein bisschen am Hadern mit mir
also es war wirklich das Beste schicken
wenn ich jetzt sag was ich hier gegessen
habe wäre es wahrscheinlich gelogen weil
ich sicher schon auch eins hatte was
Gutes aber was ich wirklich in letzter
Zeit gegessen habe wo mein Kopf sagt der
Salat war knusprig es ist was einfaches
und irgendwie glaubt mein Kopf nicht
dass du es alles so zubereitet hast weil
ich sitze hier arbeite am Laptop Meeting
du kochst und dann rufst du essen ist
fertig und geil wie wie damals zu Hause
oder da habe ich nichts gemacht habe ich
dann Videospiele g oder so und jetzt
arbeite ich ja wirklich ich würde ich
würde sagen das ist der beste ceser
salad den ich seit Jahren gegessen habe
der mir im Kopf ist du hast alles mit
Hand gemacht was echt geil ist das
Chicken war wirklich bombastisch mach
den stomi ich mach einfach so noch du
kriegst ein 9,8 also ich will dir keine
Z geben weil da hat mir dann so das
gewisse noch wow gefehlt so ich kann
nicht ohne ja du wenigstens wie Club
wenn man eine Flasche kauft so
reinkommst so deswegen nur 9,8 ich merke
du bist anspruchsvoll ne eigentlich gar
nicht ma klug zu Schi ich weiß auch gar
nicht auf das für dich ja also 7,5 auf
9,8 ich denke ST h ze geschafft aber
ja wir machen ein Club Sandwich oh ich
liebe gerade Sandwiche bin ich aktuell
dabei ich bin gespannt wie das Brot weil
mit steht und FT Sandwich ich gutener
sind das nächste sag mal wer soll gerne
noch kommen auch wenn sehr unangenehm
ist ja was sagst du W wen würdest du
denn gerne hier sehen soll ich dir
wirklich sagen W ich gerne sehen würde
du hattest schon Lotto Gewinner Chico
und dann gibt's noch Achim bubat das ist
der von den fokusreportagen der
derudio im k genau achimber Achim Buber
hier mit dir und dann ist er das und
dann Bombe Bombe wenn Achim buberz das
sieht bist du herzlich eingeladen dann
schreib mir einfach eine Mail okay wir
sehen uns zum Abendessen in der Küche
wir probieren jetzt die zehn Punkte zu
bekommen und nicht irgendwie sondern mit
einem Sandwich dass ich wirklich sehen
lassen kann wir machen ein Clubsandwich
mit einer trüffelmo und Gegrilltem
hallumi also ich beginne dem ich hier
von einer Knoblauchknolle einfach oben
bisschen was abschneide sodass wir
unseren Knoblauch auf Alufolie
platzieren können und ordentlich Fluten
mit Olivenöl wir konfieren ihn er kocht
in der eigenen Schale in Olivenöl
ordentliche Prise Salz dazu dann machen
wir das Ding zu schnür unser Paket und
geben es ab in den Ofen für ungefähr 20
bis 30 Minuten das braucht ein bisschen
bis es weich ist auf dem Clubsandwich
darf natürlich ebenfalls kein Bacon
fehlen das heißt ich lege den jetzt hier
wieder auf unserem Blech aus der Bacon
ist ausgebreitet und wir geben ihn mit
in den Ofen ich habe ein bisschen
gewartet weil der knoblau braucht schon
relativ lang jetzt kümmern wir uns um
unser chicken weil ein gutes
clapsandwich braucht definitiv chicken
da habe ich wie gerade eben auch schon
eine Brust genommen und in der Mitte
halbiert natürlich mit etwas Salz von
beiden Seiten außerdem mit etwas
geräucherter Paprika und Knoblauchpulver
dadurch wird unser chicken gerade fünf
Mal so geschmacksintensiv jetzt ist noch
die andere Seite dran genau den gleichen
Gewürzen ach so falls ihr euch fragt wie
ihr das so perfekt Sezen könnt natürlich
nur mit der blockbox die blockbox ist
das letzte Produkt was noch verfügbar
ist wir arbeiten gerade schon an der V2
von scraper und Brett das heißt wenn ihr
Lust habt schaut mal vorbei so jetzt
nehmen wir uns ein wenig hallumi und
schneiden ihn einfach in Scheiben wir
legen den jetzt einfach hier hinein in
unsere Pfanne die ist schon ein bisschen
vorgewärmt dann habe ich hier ein klein
wenig Honig DAU geb ich ein paar
Chiliflocken Aaron mag es nicht zu gerne
scharf aber das gibt so diesen leichten
Twist es wird auch nicht scharf sein so
rühren wir einmal durch so dass wir
jetzt diesen chilihonig haben und den
träufeln wir dann über unseren halumi
dass der halumi karamellisiert während
er vor sich hinbackt bisschen hoch mit
der Hitze und es sind im Prinzip einfach
nur drei Sachen in dieser Pfanne Humi
Honig Chili und am Ende des Tages ihr
werdet es gleich sehen wird das wirklich
nicht nur wunderschön aussehen sondern
auch verdammt gut schmecken ich zupfe
mir hier ein zwei Salatblätter runter
die legen wir gleich als Ganzes einfach
oben auf unser Sandwich und wasche die
einmal lass jetzt meine Pfanne mit
Olivenöl ordentlich heiß werden denn
hier drin braten wir gleich das Chicken
hier aus dem Lumi kommt schon ordentlich
die Flüssigkeit raus mal ordentlich hoch
mit der Hitze nehmen wir uns hier unser
chicken und legen das einfach in die
heiße pahne rein und jetzt ist ganz
wichtig ich mach es in der
unbeschichteten Pfanne das erst zu
bewegen wenn es schöne röstarom hat von
einer Seite während das brutzelt nehme
ich mir hier drüben eine Tomate und
schneid die einfach in Scheiben runter
dann schauen wir jetzt mal in den
Backofen was unser Knoblauch sagt
auspacken und er sollte jetzt schön hier
rauszudrücken sein man kann ih jetzt
einfach hier rausquetschen weil er so
schön gar ist sehr gut das Br wenden wir
kriegt auch von der Seite ein bisschen
Olivenöl Zack und dann wird gewendet
braen wir eine kleine Schüssel und in
diese Schüssel geben wir etwas Mayo und
Pressen unseren Knoblauch hinein dann
rühren wir das schon mal ein ihr könnt
euch vorstellen wie das schmeckt Leute
einfach so eine geile japanische Mayo
gepimpt mit Knoblauch außerdem gehen wir
ein wenig Trüffelöl ran zack das ist
geil das ist so viel geiler als einfache
Mario noch ein wenig schwarzen Pfeffer
dran jetzt probiere ich mal ich glaube
das ist eine echte Waffe geisteskrank
bauen wir ein Sandwich das es in sich
hat
[Musik]
und es wirklich so ich habe in letzter
Zeit auf meine Ernährung geachtet und
nicht so oft gegessen so einmal am Tag
richtig heute ist das dritte Mal und ich
fühle mich wie Tanzverbot rund ich hoffe
du hast noch ein klein wenig Hunger boah
kann kannst du bitte mir das in der
Mitte durchschneiden bitte magst du
lieber so ja das mag ich lieber so ich
fin das nicht das Entschuldigung find
ich gut wenn ja also das ist das
Mindeste was du dir von dem persönlichen
Koch wünschen darfst weil daran siehst
du auch jetzt direkt geiles oder nicht
wenn du es so aufmachst und ist geiler
ich hoffe du magst auch Knoblauch
bisschen aufgeregt so erstmal so an d
anlachen lassen ja oh ich brauche direkt
Z wten her Koch da links ah sorry sorry
ich dachte das wäre das Ding was du
sonst im Bett hast ist das auch das
schmeckt
ich bin sehr gespannt die Tomate guck
doch mal wie es hier tropft undes Brot
funktioniert aber also sind sehr gutes
Brot ist immer geil wenn es mit dem
Poker Face nicht so gut funktioniert a
soll Poker ich sag hast du die Soße
selbst gemacht die Soße ist Bombe ich
würde sagen wir sehen uns gleich wieder
zur finalen Bewertung aon ja reden wir
nicht lange rum doch ich muss es ein
bisschen erklären und zwar ist es so ich
gehe bei dir sehr anspruchsvoll rein es
war ein mega Sandwich und wenn meine
Frau mir das zu Hause machen würde würde
ich jubeln aber weißt du oder so mir die
Mitarbeiter aus so Mittagspause das
Mitbringen wür würde ich sagen ge geit l
zu Mittag wir gehen hin und das war
alles drei heute also Frühstück Mittag
armbrot war bombastisch wenn ich da
jetzt aber mit Anspruch reingehe habe
ich hier vor die acht gegeben 7,5 7,5
hast mir gegeben 9, ,8 und das Sandwich
hat super geschmeckt war Bombe lecker
Trüffel dies das es hat mir wieder
irgendwas gefehlt kriegst acht hey geil
ohne Witz ich bin ver hast du nicht den
Anspruch dass du ze ich will natürlich
ich will natürlichagon komm noch mal
vorbei und ich mach's besser ich find's
geil weil ich find's geil manche Leute
feiern alles krass ab aber es ist auch
immer nice jemand zu haben der so ein
bisschen kritischer an die Sache rangeht
ich auch wenn du es nicht beruflich
gelernt hast und so gehe ich bei dir
sehr hoch ran wenn mich jetzt Dave
hingesetzt hätte hätte ich mit einem Z
gegeen weil ich wusste e cool alleine
dass noch alle Finger bei dem dran sind
geil und ich könnte jetzt so luschig
sein wie der Rühl und sagen 103
Millionen Punkte aber es einfach nur
weil er Angst hat dass ihn verhaust
glaube auch da hat er hat er begründete
Angst gehabt auf jeden Fall nee es war
auf jeden Fall geil vor hinter der
Kamera sehr sympathisch und ich fordere
dich jetzt für alle in Zukunft heraus
dass du den immer noch geiles mor und
abends auch zum anbrutz ihr hab gerade
leider nur ein Piepsen gehört ich würde
sagen Freunde das war's von diesem Video
wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder
bis dahin macht's gut sch bei Aron
unbedingt vorbei ciao ciao jetzt doch
hätte ich jetzt so Kop gehabt W
vielleicht die 10 ze gewesen weißt du